it may be 2014 but from the looks of
cars hitting the road the 60s are back
in full swing it's a trend that's
persisted for years but is now more
powerful than ever before this is the
brand-new Porsche Targa the thing that
people are so excited about is the
styling it's got this silver roll bar
that harkens back to the original target
in 1965 on a totally obviously modern
sports car Chrysler is taking the design
cues from the 60s to a whole new level
giving this Dodge Challenger
a shaker cold air intake as an actual
factory option now hot rodders from the
60s would put these cold air intakes on
their muscle cars as an actor market
option keeping things colder and
producing more power but there's one
automaker who's 60 styling is a cut
above the rest is it a Camaro no is it a
Mustang no it's a necklace it's a
mash-up of the most important muscle
cars ever to come out of the Motor City
the company won't say much about its
owner but Equus is believed to be
controlled by a wealthy European car
fanatic this is the equity ace 770 it
costs $250,000 it's got 640 horsepower
and 605 pound-feet of torque but it's
not the supercharged engine that really
is the star of this car the owner wanted
to create something that was limited and
ultra high-end in performance everything
in this car is fully customizable from
the interior which is hand wrapped
leather to the exterior it's got carbon
ceramic brakes that are used from
Ferrari it's also got suspension that
has magnetic ride control like the
Corvette it is hand-built here in
Detroit they've sold about 20 so far and
they only plan on making about a hundred
this year it is going to be truly
exclusive
and while one of these souped up news 60
style supercars will cost you a quarter
of a million dollars buying original
American Muscle could cost you about the
same now or even more